>> SO, MOST OF THE DOJ'S SEARCH
WARRANT AFFIDAVIT SUPPOSEDLY
JUSTIFIES THE RATE ON MAR-A-LAGO
THAT HAS BEEN REDACTED --
ONE NAME THAT HAS PROMINENTLY
FEATURED AT THE -- IS THE FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF --
IN THE LAST ADMINISTRATION.
AS SOON AS THIS WAS REDACTED,
PEERS, MAY BE THE MOST FAMOUS
FBI AGENT -- "NEVER GREAT TO SEE
YOUR UNREDACTED NAME IN A SEARCH
WARRANT.
HERE YOU HAVE SOMEONE
THREATENING THEM ON TWITTER, BUT
WE WANTED TO SPEAK WITH THEM FOR
OURSELVES.
THEY JOIN US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
IF I WERE YOU, -- A LUNATIC LIKE
THEM.
>> HAS A LEAD INVESTIGATOR FOR
RUSSIAGATE -- ALONG WITH 16
OTHER FBI OFFICIALS, THE CORRUPT
CABAL IS BACK.
THE CORRUPTION CONTINUES.
THEY ARE BIASED, SHAMELESS.
AS A FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
PROSECUTOR, PETER STRAUSS, THE
CURRENT AGENT KNOWS THAT
AMERICA'S -- AMERICANS NAMES AND
SEARCH WARRANTS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE REDACTED.
THIS -- OF RUSSIA GATE IS NOW
BACK IN CHARGE, INTENTIONALLY --
REDACTED JUST BY NAME, AND THEN
REDACTED THE NEXT SEVEN
CONSECUTIVE PAGES.
THAT'S ALL FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES, THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE RACIST MESSAGES, BECAUSE
THEY ARE ADVERTISING -- TO GO TO
JAIL AND BE HARMED.
THE FBI DID THIS AFTER A TEN
MONTH INVESTIGATION FOR THIS
JANUARY SUBPOENA COMMITTEE, AND
ON FRIDAY THEY SUED THAT
AFFIDAVIT -- THEY ISSUE THAT
INVESTIGATION.
>> IT IS BAGGER'S BELIEF.
ONE OF THE HIGHEST RANKING
OFFICIALS OF THE FBI IS
THREATENING YOU ON TWITTER.
WHERE IS THE CURRENT FBI
DIRECTOR TO SAY "YOU CAN'T DO
THAT BECAUSE ELIMINATE ALL
PUBLIC CONFLUENCE IN THIS AGENCY
WHEN YOU DO?"
>> THE CURRENT DIRECTOR WAS --
THE FBI DIRECTOR WHEN WE WERE IN
THAT INVESTIGATION, AND HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPOSE THAT
CORRUPTION IN THE FBI AND
FAILED.
WE SIT AT THE BEGINNING, GOT OUT
60% OF THE DOCUMENTS FOR RUSSIA
GATE.
PRESIDENT  -- AND THIS ENTIRE
RAID ON HIS HOUSE, I BELIEVE,
WAS TO PREVENT THE DISCLOSURE
NOW THAT THE GOVERNMENT
GANGSTERS ARE BACK IN CHARGE.
NOW, THEY HAVE AN OPEN FBI
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
THEY ARE REJECTING -- DOCUMENTS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THIS OPEN
INVESTIGATION.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
>> THIS BEHAVIOR IS OVER-THE-TOP
TO THE NEXT TIME A MEMBER OF THE
FBI HAS KIDDIE PORN IN HIS CAR
AND THEY DON'T DO ANYTHING --
THAT'S HOW CORRUPT T